à sept mois des élections
présidentielles ils sont dans les
starting blocks pour faire gagner
emmanuel macron des mères ou des élus
yvelinois s'engage derrière le président
de la république sortant à travers des
comités locaux une initiative
transpartisane porté notamment par le
cofondateur du mouvement générations de
terrain karl olive le maire de poissy
qui a quitté le parti des républicains
il y a près de trois ans il ya aucune
difficulté que ce soit avec le président
du conseil départemental de la présence
de la région ile de france le président
du sénat parce que faut pas se tromper
de séquences moi même c'est un secret
pour personne je suis un homme de droite
j'ai voté au premier et au deuxième tour
pour valérie pécresse dans le cas de
l'élection régionale mais pour autant il
me semble que le président macron par
rapport à ce qu'il dégage par rapport
aux actions qui à mettre en place et
toutes celles qu'il faut je dirais à
porter encore une fois dans le cas de
cette campagne présidentielle coach
comme je le dis toutes les cases pour
pouvoir le soutenir ce soutien s'inscrit
dans la suite du mouvement générations
terrain créé en 2017 lors de la crise
des gilet jaune plusieurs maires
yvelinois avait rencontré le président
de la république le 7 décembre 2018 il
avait relayé les doléances de leurs
concitoyens puis le mouvement s'est
aussi rapprochée de l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe une nouvelle
étape est franchie avec ce soutien à
emmanuel macron avec plusieurs objectifs
les objectifs nous en tant qu'élu ça va
être de faire des propositions notamment
en vue de l'élaboration du projet
présidentiel je crois que ça c'est
important on a des choses à dire en tant
qu'élu notamment dans la relation entre
les collectivités et l'état a été
rappelé aujourd'hui et puis on va
essayer de fédérer fédérer largement et
je crois que c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant que ce soit les mères qui
prennent ce flambeau là fédérer au delà
des partis politiques fédérer au delà de
toutes les sensibilités
aujourd'hui 25 communes ont déjà leur
comité local à travers 150 élus locaux
des yvelines d'autres villes pourraient
accueillir des comités locaux de soutien
au président de la république